[Musique]
pour demain olivier lui débutera après
demain après sa jeune consoeur dimanche
n'est ce pas sur l'antenne pour
présenter les programmes de la soirée
c'est la soirée voilà alors olivier lui
aussi aime beaucoup la télé mais c'est
un passionné de théâtre comme vous allez
le constater sur ces images notre
reportage c'est juliette c'est le soleil
de minuit madame
elle parle
parle encore
ronit en parlera plus ton nom
et un échange prendra toute entière je
te prends mon nom mois seulement amour
ce sera comme un autre baptême
jamais plus je ne serai et roméo qui es
tu quitteras du châssis sont dépensés
cycle est
marocain non je ne saurais te dire qui
je suis puisque je hais le mien ont
belle jeune fille d'être ton ennemi
comment es tu venu dit sur les ailes
légère de l'amour j'ai volé par dessus
les murs
aucun mur de pierres ne peut empêcher
l'amour de voler
c'est pourquoi je ne craque pas ta
famille je me battrai
et ça lui arrive souvent olivier minne
de jouer les roméo comme ça dans paris
notre hymne bien les deux jeunes filles
sont là n'ont rarement j'ai rarement
conter fleurette comme ça depuis une rue
alors olivier sera sur le sens nantes à
dimanche comme le laisse supposer la
couleur de ses yeux de ses cheveux ce
garçon est d'origine belge
en plus ce n'est pas une blague belge
tout à fait tout à fait bon comment il
en est venu à la télévision livier pour
finir et bien c'est une passion depuis
autres qui m'est venue depuis très
longtemps et puis voilà quand on a envie
on fait tout pour bon ils seront sur le
minitel très prochainement olivier
gerolami il très vraiment y voilà
[Musique]